Testing. Testing. Ah, ah, Micah. Okay.
We shall not puke. No, you shouldn't puke. You shall not puke.
No, you shouldn't. It's not a bomb. I'm trying so hard.
Look at this audio jingle jingle jingle. That's so funny.
That's actually really funny. Don't give me that one.
Oh no, it's not on live chat. Why does it do that?
I threw up. No, stop throwing up. I'm here. I'm here.
Can you hear me? It's like I can still hear a voice.
Am I live? Can you hear me this time? Good morning, good evening, good after.
I didn't leave yet. I said yesterday and mark my words.
I said yesterday, the next time I come online, the missing audio will be up.
Just because I uploaded the audio two minutes ago doesn't mean I didn't stay true to my word.
It's on Patreon right now and it's the most ridiculous thing I've ever produced in my life.
Okay? It was bizarre. Truly bizarre. I have no idea what anyone's gonna think of that audio.
But, you know, as always later, if you wanna send a marshmallow for a little review
just to give me a few tips, pointers, or anything that you'd preferred in the moment,
please do remove personal preference to objective preference if you actually
unironically wanna leave a review. But that was the...
It's unfair making us choose between you and you.
Now, do you have a few updates?
I got eight hours of fucking sleep, baby.
And I can't remember what the fucking song is.
I got eight hours of sleep.
I'm exhausted, but mentally, I feel on my way to recovery, okay?
I feel on my way to recovery. I basically had an epiphany yesterday.
And the long and short of it was...
I don't need to give advice if advice isn't wanted.
And it was like the shackles had been taken off me.
Release me!
Basically, sigmalokinas, as soon as I get a nanoblade.
Eh, a nanoblade, that's not what it's called. It's called a nano from Anna.
Literally, the shackles have been unbound and it was as simple as
just ask them if they want advice.
And for those who say, yes, give them advice, I'm a fucking idiot.
I was trying to give advice to people who don't want it.
Ah! Ah!
And all this mental anguish and exhaust and stress of, you know,
trying to make someone as successful as I could possibly make them, gone.
Because I'm an idiot and I had to fucking realize
people, some people don't want advice and that's fine.
I can't insist on like a dumbass!
I can't insist on like, no, Strani, no, stop!
Literally banging on the window.
No, Strani, stop! She doesn't want that advice! Stop!
And now the shackles have been removed off of me.
I've had my first eight hours of sleep and my fucking mantra is
what will be, will be!
Oh, I feel so good.
I feel so good.
It's gone.
It's over.
I do have a cup of tea, so I'm going to yapp tea and read
marshmallows for a little bit whilst I have my cup of tea
because I never drink my tea in time.
Um, I got what I want, but what I want, and I'm done, yeah.
Actual back-setting, here's hoping there are actions that start new rules.
I don't give a fuck, you're on your own.
You're on your own.
And my life has become my favorite thing in the world I want to hear.
I wake up every day in those first eight hours of the day.
All I can do is wait to hear those words.
Am I, is that how I start all the time?
Am I live?
I'm wait, because I click start broadcast way before any of you go
hi, mummy.
Um, Winston, I didn't give him a beat.
Bruh, I'm not going to lie, I was so fucking depressed yesterday.
I hopefully was able to hide it and shit, but I knew it was one of
those things where the solution is about to come, but the solution
couldn't come during the stream.
It had to come after, and then the solution walked into my arms
and I give a big hug and I'm like, oh, I just need to like, oh, like, oh,
I don't like, oh, everything's fine now.
Everything's fucking hunky-dory, I'm happy.
First eight hours sleep in actual months, in actual pre-debut months,
unironically, first...
Oh, I'm doing fantastic reflux, and how the fuck are you doing this
fine morning, evening, and afternoon?
Mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah.
You never let go of a tentacle, no, no, no, see that, no, that's a different
kind of input that you need, or a different kind of input that I need.
The game is paused, by the way, you will hear no background game pausing.
It's a full screen, like, Lego Lord of the Rings is a full screen game,
so when I'm not in it, you won't hear it.
You are my...
Oh, you want me to sing Sunshine?
I don't know if it makes the reflux sad when I sing Sunshine.
Good morning, good morning.
The last part was a strange kiss, not bad though.
Hi, huh, it was a bit sticky, it was a bit sticky, what's going on here?
I'm also strongy happy to be here with you.
Oh, I'm alright strongy, sorry, I thought you were making a joke, sorry.
Love all your hard work, but your physical mental health, bruh, bruh, I'm not even,
I'm not even kidding, I'm gonna be so productive.
Like, basically the long and short is first time I've ever kind of,
I've like, so this sounds really sad, but I've just accepted that my gen mate
see me as the boss, and there's no point in crying over spilt milk.
So now that I've accepted that, it's like, okay, I don't need to worry about that
because, you know, they don't see me as a pal, they don't come to me, so that's fine, okay.
Next, right, those who don't want advice and are not taking it right, I don't need to give
them anything, I can just let them do the thing, they can do the wrong thing.
Fuck, why did it take me so long to understand that?
Okay, and then I said to them, yeah, I said, you know, they'll be shy to put streams up
just a little bit, and then I'll wake up and everyone's got their streams up,
what the fuck, what the fuck!
And I was like, oh shit, they're actually listening, it feels good back.
That's kind of sad, not gonna lie.
I mean, like, I said in the interview stage, don't treat me like a boss, and yeah,
and they all said, yeah, no, that's fine, and then they've all done it, and it's fine.
I'm not singling out anyone, literally all of them see me as like some sort of
boss authority figure.
There's no point in forcing that I'm your pal angle if all of them are, like,
all of them equally are setting it.
So there's no point in, you know, crying over spilt milk.
If anything, you know, it just kind of feels like that let-and-go ability to be able to let go of,
like, I want them to see me as a friend, a gen mate, so badly, but, you know, I got communicated
across the board, all of them were like, yeah, sorry, I'm scared of you, the sississ,
and I'm like, okay, you a boss, so I don't dictate anything they do, they do what they want,
all that jazz, and I give them advice if they want it now, basically.
I started today, I was trying to give advice, but then I realized some don't actually want it
in the way that I want to give it.
So, like, that was another thing I let go, and like, it's the feeling of let-and-go,
and it's like, just whatever we'll be, we'll be, and I'm just like, I just feel so much better,
because I'm like, fuck, I'm gonna focus on my streams, I'm gonna focus on my reef lands,
I'm gonna do my thing, because, you know, there's no point in any of this, really,
there's no point in me being so wind up, being so stressed, being so upset about the reality,
don't, you know, there's no point in being upset about what the reality or the fact of the matter
is, you know, sorry, I'm gonna drink my tea, it's getting cold.
Big boss, boss of my tentacle, you gotta weasel your way in over time, no, I'm absolutely not,
look, as they, it's very clear, you know, they see, they don't see me as a friend,
they see me as like, that kind of person who hired you to take things, so, thus your boss,
and I'm like, I'm not forcing it, if they don't want to talk to me, they don't have to talk to me.
I'm trying, you didn't choose the boss, let the boss, well, that's the thing, I feel like, well,
all things considered, I'm hardly a boss, but whatever.
So, as I said, letting go has been fantastic, I literally had my first eight hours sleep, and
hi honey, hi refling, in solidarity with you, I'm not gonna, until you do it, bro, you're gonna
be waiting a lo- ah, it's time, you're gonna be waiting a long ass time, that's still possible,
this is the seventh time of, mm-hmm, and to your pre- pre-edge audio,
pre-edge, the training one, dropping an audio right before stream is so mean, what do you mean,
you don't want to watch me get a hundred percent and lego lord of the ring for eight hours before
you can finally listen to the, I think it was 16 minutes long it came out, so, good thing we see
you as our wife and the love of our life, and not our boss, then feels good, man, we'd very much
like to experience the last part, what happened in those cases, you can on Patreon right now,
patreon.com slash stony calls, five dollars a month, you can get access to four
audios, and I also put all my early access stuff for YouTube on it too, because there's
quite a lot of things that I upload that can't be put on YouTube right at this very moment,
because I currently am on a warning, maybe, um, I'm so happy you're happy, I love you,
I love you too a little, literally, I did get a few marshmallows offline about you guys worrying
about stress, now, obviously, you know, yesterday between like, how long I've been awake, I finally
found the relief of just let go, and now it's like gonna, it's gonna take a few days to register
that I can let go, but yeah, like, yeah, I'm happy, I'm very happy, um, after this stream,
I hope to actually get AC's YouTube role play up, um, Mercy might be having another YouTube
role play up at some point, um, it's a bit of a beast of a script, I gave her quite a big script,
not gonna lie, it was a big role play, it's probably, yeah, it's longer than the most common
stuff I get her to record, but I think it would do quite well, um, so whether or not she does have
the time to record it, that's a whole different, as I said, like, that's optional, like, over,
not in the contract, like, you have to produce like one YouTube audio role play, no, that's not
in the contract, the force of habit remains, truly, okay, I'm gonna open up the game,
okay, I've almost finished with, oh, okay, oh, can you take, no, no, no, no, not back speed,
can you take input from the controller that's clearly polylogged in right now, that would be
great, instead of my mouse and keyboard, please stop using my mouse and keyboard, please stop
using my mouse and keyboard, I pray, who is player two, how do I drop out via mouse and keyboard,
I said it's quick game, what, so this is, so that's my mouse and keyboard,
and then this is my keypad, and it says drop out, bro, I ain't playing WASD on
Lord of the Rings, are you joking, no, get the shit off, how do I change the option,
control,
what, you never did this to me yesterday, why are you doing it to me now, quick to Windows,
quick to game, quick game, quick game, quick to Windows, just quick to Windows, why did you do
that, hold on, let me, I'll re-boost it, I'm not sure why I did that, change device that bought
my control set, you mean it was that simple, you mean it was that simple, it sees, it sees,
it's doing the key, it's doing the mouse, no, it's doing the key,
the controller, geez, out with the woman, slot number two, would you come,
okay,
okay, let's discover minister, because I don't think we discovered the map on minister, okay, so
we just get you up to speed, if you were unable to join yesterday, please don't worry, if you
can't skip through the board either, it's very long, so we need to go pick up the enemy, and his
name is Berserker, and he hides under a bridge out in Mordor, and if we can find him,
I'm sure Berserker is around this area, now this is just a regular Uruk-hai, this isn't Berserker,
I've got an achievement, it's called one, just not simply walking from Mordor, where,
I could have sworn Berserker's purchasable here, am I going to mean, oh game is a bit loud, is that
actually, okay, I will change the in-game audio for your ears sir, oh yeah, I will put it to five,
and then you'll tell me who it is, oh, I could have sworn, can I, can I cheeky doodle, I thought,
I could have sworn Berserker was here, am I going to meant, oh, oh, Rethlings, can you maybe look up
like Lord of the Rings where Berserker is, I could have sworn he was here, are you squinting me right
now, you can't 100% in one stream, I bet you 50 memberships, you can't 100% in one stream,
I mean, easy 50 memberships, I'll literally do this on my own, like 15 times over,
he's over there, thank you, okay, you're done, hi Kupa, I'm so sorry about your wallet, but I
literally do this all the time, I've played this game multiple times, I thought Berserker's at night,
maybe he is at night, you know that, might be a night time, out in the front of Helm's
Deep, next to the large, you'll find an Urkai, head up the eastern, and Berserker's at Helm's
Deep, next to the large staircase, you'll find Urkai 12, head up the eastern staircase outside
the wall to find Berserker, Berserker's at Helm's, that's Minas Teres, Berserker's at Helm's Deep,
are you Berserker, no you're an Urkai, is he a night boy,
Berserker sleeps under the bridge you said, so night makes sense, hold on, hold on,
night time at Helm's Deep, got it, so he needs to be in Helm's Deep, go up the eastern wall,
what, head up the eastern staircase outside the wall, Sam you're not, I think, what you mean is up the,
oh, oh, oh, oh, where the fuck is it, where the fuck is it, Berserker you're BAM, where are you,
I need you before I can even play the main campaign, oh my god I can't believe everyone
knows that I'm a fake fan of this game, there you are you BAM, take this, so you need to beat
him up and then you can buy him, we did it, we have everyone we need to play campaign mode,
okay so this is now that we've done that, okay we go all the way back into it all over again,
and it's the best thing ever, okay, so basically strap in, strap in, so we do it all over again,
we have Gollum for climbing walls, Gandalf for magic, Berserker for blowing up Legolas for
arrows, Hulk smashing stuff on the ground, and we've got a seal door for anything,
more like strap on, I assure you there was no strap on in the last audio,
and I do want to say one thing, there is a bread in the oven, the odds of it coming out
today during stream, I'm not sure, we might have to do an oven break, you're the death sound,
free plays when the Lego game really starts, literally it's like after playing the campaign,
so where do we do now, mommy's pregnant, no it means I have a big massive joby up
morse and it won't come out, right we're gonna skip the things, but let's see, okay it's right,
it's right side when we do this, okay, it's right side when we do this, right, oh no, oh my god,
I forgot Berserker, I forgot about orange handles, oh my gosh, I completely forgot about orange
handles bro, you were making me nervous, making me nervous as fuck, what's going on here, give me that,
okay so now there's a pathway to get along to that one as well, hi Tony, how are you, I'm going
fucking amazing yeah, we are currently doing free play mode to get all of the missing items,
achievements etc, as long as my stamina is ever enduring then we will be able to just do it in
one go in this stream, and yeah, I don't really got much else to it, but yes I'm doing good, I hope
you guys are doing good as well, I ain't feeling for the well today, so I'll be watching, wait if
you aren't feeling well, shouldn't you be lying down and looking after yourself, oh it's a gimly
smash, oh wrong button, gimly smash, oh I missed, don't you didn't see that, that was embarrassing,
oh my god that's actually embarrassing, right is that, are we done now, no we need San, we need Frodo
to look at the last one, then, has he not come out there, you you bam, have I not covered the last
one, maybe I haven't, oh there is, I knew it, I knew it, I knew it, lying in bed with chicken
watching strongy since he's cute, good idea, I'll give you some of my chicken soup next time, okay
is it just stuff to destroy, okay I don't think there's anything else here that I can think of,
unless there's like some secret like, you must destroy all the cobwebs, I don't actually recall
if it's only two pickups in this room, but I'm gonna start shooting, anyway I start blasting,
please serenade me with more Lord of the Rings fat, oh you're more than welcome, did you know
that pre-production for Lord of the Rings was like two years or something,
but then pre-production for the Hobbit was literally four months, and then everyone
ships on up, and then like that, okay I don't think there's anything else here, if there is then
we'll try our best, right um we also need to snipe any birds nests that we see, now that we have a
a crossbow, now that we have a bow and arrow, not to be confused with a bow and arrow, no no,
um if we see any birds nests we'll shoot them down, and then that will be another little trinket for us,
little trinket, oh we've already got true adventure, but we didn't even have to try for it,
aw, Gimli and Lego have gone on an adventure together, thank you Alvaki, I said that terribly
well, and reverse, I don't think I've said your name either, I'm actually so excited to play the
game, I'm forgetting all the rules of being a Vtuber right now, I knew that because you told me,
I imagine you were able to reuse a lot of what they had, I don't know because it was a different IP,
so they used Weta Workshop, Weta Workshop is the New Zealand workshop that um there's a
stud behind here, yoy my studness, um Weta Workshop is like who worked on that stuff and yeah they
had like the same kind of team involved many many a year later, um but the actual IP because of you
know Winston IP is obtained by a movie, um producer Warner Brothers for example, you know it's up to
them if they give permission for that kind of cross-use of assets, but uh I don't be surprised
if they have to like start from scratch, concepts from scratch, like if you didn't know the hobbit
actually the bad guy in the hobbit was going to be like a skinny wee one, um and then Peter Jackson
you know he changed his mind about it because he was like no this just isn't gonna work, like
so many things got scrapped, I mean that's what happens in production anyway, like sorry Peter
Jackson move aside but nothing will beat my fondle of bosom experience, um is there a bird's nest
before I forget, I swear I miss the bird's nest every time I play this damn game, um no also every
built stage was obviously destroyed after the shoot, yeah that as well like these kind of reused assets
really the only thing they could reuse was like major concert or something, fun fact about the
Lego Hobbit game it was released before the third movie came out and they were gonna make the rest
of the game 3DLC but that never happened because the licensing issues, yep that sounds a bit right,
I didn't know it actually came out, Gandalf was almost Sean Connery the Scottish guy, no he's no
Scottish is he, no no I'm just making stuff up, surely they reused the hobbit in the scenes,
they maybe reused the schematics to produce bag ends inside and stuff like that, like these
kind of concept things are fine to share, reuse or whatever, maybe, I don't know IP is a nightmare,
I cannot tell you how much of a nightmare IP is like, we had some before we you know boot it up
there were some website inquiries by quite notable content creators and you know they were like can
I keep my IP because I really like the concept of what you're doing and we had to be like no sorry
it's an absolute nightmare, we cannot, we would if the if the girl retains her IP while under
we would have to go to her to ask for permission to produce like the most basic promotional material
the most basic this the most basic that like it's an absolute nightmare, I'm I want to I know some
people oh my god so cool the agency so you keep your IP yeah well not mine I ain't touching that
shit with ten foot pool the lawyer was like um I'm glad that you want to be so like fair so nice
in that but don't do it you are just gonna end up miserable and I was like okay we'll get we get
we money, that is real love you strong but I'll be honest with my priorities I just want to watch
the larger the ring gameplay stop that's funny that's funny I'll give you you know what I'll give
you that one I'll give you that one chief um swing them see like you can go nice and slow
I'm just a note you wouldn't part an old man with his walking stick now would you
and then he's tired
and hope you're ready to strap into the field campaign and before I actually can't do it one
day that would actually be at least one verse what are we doing tomorrow I actually don't know my
schedule at all you guys know my schedule better than I'm doing I'm the one who body pixel the stuff
on it and
oh I heard about that vtuber news yeah that company got sold to brave girl and I'm like oh
so yeah um I wish luck to all the talents because that's scary beans and I have reassured my girls
the company is never being sold to anyone and I couldn't give less of a shit what the fucking
offer is not that anyone would because you know loot company bad but uh yeah uh I reassured all the
girls the this company is never swapping hands this is my child this is my everything um you know
so I shan't be having any any of that but I do understand that things happen and
you've been at things for a long time uh yeah yeah the talents can leave the company and take
the ip with them for free mommy too stubborn to even get investors literally in the audio I
start teasing you and I start calling you the investor vealer oh my are you the investor vealer
yeah basically it's how the audio goes babies are my no no literally I birthed them from my loins
blood sweat and tears I'm gonna save just on the basis to get rid of that thing at my point of view
okay this is where the birds nests are okay um literally I had those babies in my womb
for um literally 12 months the first concept Emi was given in June so I've had them in my
tummy for an entire year I'm gonna snipe this bird's nest before I forgo there you go one of
five maybe um uh great raid so mommy is great yeah you enjoy her she was a wee cutie pie I felt
so bad but I was like played lord of the rings thank you for looking after the wrestling spy but I
do get pretty exhausted after a stream but she's a cutie pie she is going mental on that game though
but I have to admit I'm tempted to play the botany corp after um yeah let me direct the other day
I've actually put it in my schedule but I need to watch someone play it so I don't
uh right we need to become Sam I want to go back I want to be monkey
let's get Legolas
there's two is that third one right after it normally the legal game kind of spreads them out but
you don't want the surprise the blink effects honestly bro I'm like never doing that again for
myself right let's do this good everyone I could snipe from here can I snipe that one from here
that's so far away oh right I'm gonna keep Legolas out I'm gonna go Gimli I want to be Gimli
and we're smashed this are you sure lobotomy corp is difficult mom cut right fine I'll look
up gameplay I'll look up gameplay I'm not just gonna I'm not gonna dolphin dive into it don't
you worry I'll look up gameplay right who does the fish Mary does fishy
baby it's better this way
um
Legolas and then you throw it Legolas
I still love watching you every time something interesting happens my internet dies and every
time my internet dies I put no that's so sad I can't believe your your internet is keeping us
away from each other we must destroy it
um so there's gonna be a few things I think there's two things back here oh my god why am I
just so mlg pro like why do I remember every little thing that happens in this game I don't know
like just just kiss me already do you just see you love me
and then we've got an aragon scent a little bit of scent plates actually I never did any scent
play in that audio oh my god I'm such a failure I'm sorry I'm such a failure I can't believe
I did that no simply is it even a real audio for me if there's no simply mentioned in my
pheromone maxim actually I'm really fucking disgusting I need a shower I'm not even kidding
like I'm actually I'm in the same fucking undies still like three days now so I'm actually
making sauce actually you need to send me in the shower ironically you need to put me in the shower
no is he gonna drop is he gonna no don't drop it aragon I will cry so hard please don't drop it
no don't drop it I'm gonna cry I'm gonna cry am I going mental why is this not breaking
it doesn't break why do they not do it I don't know do not drop that aragon do you understand
me young man you understand me cancer
you did a little bit of scent so even your ass is at the party yeah I know but I did the
take a shower be honest mommy what are the undergarments they're the same pantyloons
is that a pad for the wee while now disgusting yeah and I said it I said it oh no I've forgotten
there's a location that I forgot about was it before the river I think we're about to do the
biggest backtrack ever I'm not even kidding
tonight the music seems so loud I wish we can get out this bird
oh my god do you want to know a secret achievement if you put the washroom hat on him he should
get a secret achievement I guess not I'll give you the fuck about it
I have forgotten there's a pathway back this way if I if it's not being oh god there's two
items I'm missing oh what the fuck I'm such a fake gamer I'm missing two items what the hell
no I can't go back I can't go back I'm so oh my god I can't believe you've discovered my secret
I don't actually like playing this game there's two items there's like a skeleton thank god gollum
be creepy and I wouldn't want that I'm such a fake gamer right okay well we'll we'll carry on
forth we need to go to the right side not the left stop going left side do you understand me
yes okay I can't believe it I forfeit the 50 memberships I just suck
it is there's a little secret passing that you go down it's really well hidden it's before the dang
river okay right say right sad ladies and gentlemen right sad
I can't believe I just played this game for male attention you've got
hook lane and sinker I cannot deny it I have to be the shy not a gamer but I'm marinating in
her underwear for literally shamelessness I shouldn't have to start the entire game again
gollum be 2pd 2pd coming for the booty honestly the animation is good 12 endurance at 12 I don't
know if I've got 12 hours and if I really want to do that AC audio because I think it'll do well
I just need to record the folly sound because I'm adding like I'm updating the sound darker as you
can tell I'm I'm humping the right side of the screen come on come on baby come on baby
I'm on the right I'm on the right I'm on the right hey okay we at least got that one so we're
missing two items
where where are the two I am
I think I might have an inclin we have an inclination
but yeah we at least so we're gonna get two myth rules because one we did adventure adventure
honey and we got third keys we get a few thing y'all
not in your food did we win for the most part yeah
well what are we building this shire
are we hobbitin no what that didn't look like anything but we got extra monies for that and
we got a mushroom crane I've got black smith the same uh mithril music corn
shire has houses yeah brie maybe yeah maybe because we're going to the front
no you're right you're right you're right yeah yeah you're right yeah yeah you're right
right that's true that's true
being sick and watching strongy's the best medicine I've seen
I strong so I don't know I must go high now
um we'll go back for the missing stuff so we'll move on to weather top
and adventure time uh we'll do throttle with the elven hit it with the oh oh oh
such a fake fan I know that is ogre it's ogre lord of the rings I'm sorry right we are
going to skip the cutscenes because I have played this game yes I hope that's it's understandable
I like when the game gives you really easy items literally that counts as an item
I'm like thank you does he have a rope yeah he does I like that you can swap between stuff as well
like as you muck about come on we duck hell met honestly Legolas means business sorry but that's
what his name literally translates to okay there's good fraud over the late and then I think that
may be this area done already we just gotta do the actual campaign mode stuff shocker behavior
what are you as he goes fishing rod in his arbor but how will I know the lore
the lore why did no one think of the lore implication what's going on
well I guess
hope that they're put that in the pan put that in the pan hey put that in the pan hey put that in the
pan hey we're just gonna zoom through this area because as I said we've already got all the
pickups in this particular section the map I have the most issues with is the path of lordy dog
which is not how it's called but um it is the biggest issue I have with anything I'm just gonna take a
I'm just gonna manipulate the camera angle to look a little bit around just thinking there's
nothing you know something hidden on a wall I'd rather try my best to get everything Legolas
Legolas ask this hairdresser to get a little bit more oh I thought it was a bee to pick it up
I I can't believe it I have lost valuable two seconds 2.5 seconds on my speed run I might as
well just do a reset right now resetting right now you heard it here for every set
I love that in a speedrun where they are like oh that didn't work I'm just gonna do a hard reset
because like they lost like 0.1 seconds of progress I'm like bruv this game this is too intense for
me I don't know how I couldn't get into speedrunning I'd be so annoyed if I messed up viable five
coins you lost your credibility um adventure time oh complete two cooking puzzles what about
second break this is the cheapest look yet as I said well just speedrun it should be yeah the
design in there I remember I'm so smart I'm a smart bean sometimes maybe not all the time
an adventure time
would hobbits go for a third breakfast I don't know probably aren't they like bottomless pits
somehow or is it just that they're very cultured and they know the food is good so it's you know
going good I'm just gonna check there's nothing hidden back here but now okay it just seems like that one
you might like micro speedrun in that last like 30 seconds wait I'm sure there's that like
007 game that's like a pixel and it like you can speedrun it in like 56 seconds or something crazy
like that I know we already I'm pretty sure we already did the flower but I'm just doing it just
thinking just thinking isn't that branch considering the time of day you know I don't know it's like
what second breakfast 11 z's what are you a Lego last moment oh my god I didn't even know that was there
I forgot about that thank goodness it had the petal to uh tell me what to do because yeah I'm gonna
clock that so I made a joke that all the books in the Lord of the Rings here are actually hobbit
cookbook stop I want to do um cooking if I could somehow set up cooking stream you know full well
we're gonna be making like hobbit meals of some accord like she be made that cake yesterday um
and like she told me what she did in the stream and I was like um do you mind if I turn some of that
stuff into clips because I was a membership stream but the clip that you have to understand is such
good clip quality and she was like show me show me first and I'll like okay I'll show you first
before I do anything but uh yeah her fucking stream went very well so congrats to the harem
um welcome to the reef kitchen today we're making more Lord of the Rings things maybe
all the Lord of the Rings okay so that was a that was just a POV hint to what's around the corner
I'm in the corner watching you kiss her uh oh this is definitely a Sam kind of mission
close the good membership hello hello I'm gonna cut right clip equal free advertising for that
membership relauncher yes the clipping program is going to come out maybe
maybe by the end of this week um
yeah question mark I don't I need to write up the fucking like I don't know I've had eight hours
like I don't want to jinx it but I might be able to do an endurance and then still have some in the
tank you know um I'm gonna try and get true adventure but it's really not a big deal if I don't
get it like actually not yeah I think there's also an item back here
royal armor oh I hate the smelly ones sounds good don't push yourself yes um I think it's
probably the next natural progression for growth like um that Emmy clip you know how I keep going
back to that Emmy clip and being like X amount of people have seen it almost 200 000 people I've seen
my little sister's honkers what's going on what's going on but um yeah it definitely seems like the
the natural progression uh why are you smelling is this just a glitch it's just a glitch um okay so
yeah I am just gonna get left over okay next honk honk maybe honk on my sister right what's
going on oh no I forgot the game does things like this no we have to come back
we need miss real bow and arrow and a miss real boxing gloves
no I forgot the freaking game does stuff like this
get out of here we can't progress
draft I forgot the freaking thing I told she be that you would want to click that stream
we're on the same wavelength okay so I'm just trying to put them on
um that's so annoying we're gonna have to go back we must return to monkey um
every time I join that clip is mentioned brav because I'm so shocked I'm like so um I kind of
thought some clipping channels would maybe like clip some stuff like either of the debuts or other
than that but like it's really just being you guys that have been clipping us which I'm so
thankful for like there's literally a um a big brother that's like a dedicated clip channel
to emmers in that and I'm like that's like so amazing um but I do have to confess like I thought
oh like Azura had a very clippable moment during her debut where she was literally panting with her
togo um and like it nothing happened with it and and yeah just really surprised but then
smoothie like clipped us and then we all saw a massive boom and subscribers and like that kind
of thing and then I was like hey so I'm just gonna do a clipping program because clearly that stuff
works you know um you need to kill all the skeletons that have a hat on them um
but yeah okay so this one's a bit annoying but yeah so the skeleton doesn't have a hat on it
so you're not going to get the one of five on him all skeletons with a hat um
I want a strong new program now the program is for all veal it doesn't matter who you clip
so you get a ten dollar base fee and then two dollars per one key views up to a max of like
I'm definitely honking emmy next week's stuff um yeah like I found vealor from smoothies clips
it's literally literally proof proof of concept proof of concept um because yeah it's definitely
like the next natural progression of like how I promote them well because obviously we did the
watch along sadly they just went shit a lot of people just wearing new fuss which was a shame
like I said it was 12,000 for that big offer we did I think it was actually turned out to be 14,000
or something like or something crazy like that um we got that skeleton with a hat on so we're good to
go um you're so open about everything just as open as my leg thank you thank you I'll be here all week
get it because I'm slack can we be paid to kidnap and take into the farm
clips are a big seller yeah like I definitely through the research and
seeing what like how other creators like got successful or big or whatever like there's
absolutely no shadow of a doubt clipping is it so in order to incentivize people to join the
clipping program it's what you have to be accepted oh bless me I've got to be accepted yet um but it's
ten dollars per base of a clip that you upload of the girl and then two dollars per thousand views
it gets but the height the ceiling height is 100,000 views so for one clip that goes viral
you can be paid 210 dollars us for that and that's how it's worked out and you know I had a big
discussion with the team kind of like you know I obviously a lot of history content creation
history went behind those numbers as well because people will be like oh can you even afford that
thing and it's like um you have to one you have to actually be accepted like as a clipper like
you can't you you don't just apply and then money starts falling at your feet like you'll get invited
into a clipper discord and it's all regulated like every 30 days you can you'll submit what clips you
like want your additional payout for type thing um and all that I need to work it out because um
there has to be so many things where it's like if it's clear you're spamming low quality clips
you're not putting any edit and into them that kind of thing then you know we'll just kick you
out the program basically because obviously we need our money's worth and you know it ain't just
like one big massive cash grab the skeleton has a hat on them so stop it Mary aim for the skeleton
jeez where's it pipping break the skeleton jeez that was like so long just post 50 clips a month
that's rent like if it's as I said obviously it is more for established clip channels because
that's where we're going to get our money's worth we can't just you know accept everyone and I explain
to the girls like as much as we root for the underdog at all times this is one of those things where
it needs to be cost effective which sounds so shite but as hopefully time progresses and
income increases um you know um we can take it from there but as it's just going to be
trialed one month is going to be the trial and if we think it's working you know I'll discuss with
the girls at the next meeting and be like this is the results we've kind of found across the
oh apply um yeah I'll just tell them like oh this is the results we've found I don't know what you
think or um and maybe one of those things where we pause it one month or whatever I don't know I don't
know it's the first time I've ever done it so okay let's see how it goes no point in uh no point in
not uh trying to try and do something fun exciting different uh we'll take it from there need a lego
yeah unfortunately this map is really rough I never remember it properly and we're together
things are they taking the hobbits I think if you post 50 good clips then you're just a chef
cooking a lot yes because the thing is we don't submit the clips you upload to the girls obviously
the kind of value in offering like the different uh the base price and the additional fee is that
um you know you go find those clips of what the girl's done obviously no one's gonna go
or it's Johnny's own fucking lego lord of the rings there's gonna be tons of like clickable
clickbait clips on that like no that's not how it's gonna work you're gonna have to go find them
clips when when giving them to you um so that's kind of the incentive to be like hey you should
check out the girl uh we're actually gonna do two gimbals because you're gonna stop by the snow
I will continue to click moments I like and not upload them to YouTube because I don't want to what
um I'm actually getting ready to send a wrist of my third batch so the way I work with a wrist
like she's like my personal editor and uh we've done batch one we're doing batch two and I'm about
to go through all of my clips to do batch three with her um which I'm excited about we did end
up clipping the binding of Isaac win but unfortunately Rissa didn't know and um I'm still gonna pay her
for it but the clip didn't work out which is a shame but because my reaction was so subdued as well
and it was like a last minute like oh my god I did it like I hardly reacted at all to be honest
it was pretty ruffle with clip and but I'm gonna be a bit more careful with clips as a mix obviously
ow proof berserk no this is the thing with berserker he never aims he never aims literally
he's a mean nightmare oh well that that boosted my income a bit after I've done that right you
go gimme right now then you can you pick him up no you've got a bomb in your hand you can
don't tell the elf you're very exhausted after it
gaush relic go
okay no become berserker and then open this what is it oh it's just a chest well it's not joseph
and
oh John
okay I'll do everything I thwarted but I didn't shit it yet I made she did soon
you've got a hat but you didn't count why did that all count he has he literally has a hat
oh sorry sorry sorry didn't mean to wallop you all right what am I supposed to do
I'm uh I'm supposed to get him across the snow sorry
you didn't share with the class shame shame shame shame shame
hey I actually just put banding with Isaac because of you oh wait until November
you're gonna be off that game you're all stream sniping me in November it's ogre truly it's over
oh I see ha point point point is this four oh we did it right we got that right I've got
material down here so I'm gonna blow this up and then I'm gonna become Frodo so I can go in the
dark with this little flare I'm gonna grab that and no you do not come up so I have to keep opening
the menu or it will teleport me to the other um guy constantly let's know how the bacon goes later
I'm not like other stupid literally like me oh oh so uh maybe hopefully the program goes well
and I'll get a few clips also me I am constipated as fuck right now yeah I'm sure people want to
clip the absolute living daylights out of that jeez well worse woman if you've already found the
design it gets replaced with a stud of um can I skip this bit
oh I can yeah I can just kind of skip the thing where I'm at
I will batter stuff as uh Gimli though just in case there's something hidden I don't think there's
anything
no I don't think there's anything that'll melt it yeah Sam will burn it and then that's it really
no there's nothing here oh game blue time to throw you you'd be surprised poop right now no it's
stuck in my boy stuck in my digestive tract and nothing's happening thunder battle
right we're gonna skip skip bidi do da skip bidi day my oh my what a wonderful
we've got a raiding crawl bell's raiding who the fuck is Bill right this is one of those things
where if you don't do it you wouldn't realize you must use the horse and follow the lane and then
you will get a piece of treasure I was going absolutely nuts trying to figure out what the
missing thing was but it doesn't display if you ain't on the horse say you know what I'm saying
you ain't on the horse I ain't displaying okay what else is special about this area there is
a secret area to the left which might have the last of what we need I'm not quite sure yet I'm not
quite sure but I want to discover so look look see how the game's prompt and yet jump up no rejects
jump up go into cavern right okay so this is a really annoying thing this breaks all the time
because he throws the lollipop away and it might bug out and if it does I just want to say I called
it because it happens all the time to me he throws the lollipop secret cavern secret cavern so the item
inside is a lollipop right and it's no no no see how it tries to put it outside the door so you
can't pick that shit up what are you I mean I know it's a cavern
I'm destroying everything I don't think I get anything for destroying the ace it's not that I
recall not that I can recall I don't think so no no don't oh dear right let's call them up the small
again go lump and then we're going to give this guy a fish that's so juicy sweet
all I wish to catch a fish
like an actual lollipop yeah like a lollipop no I'm not in here A.C. like a lollipop he's
a nice lolly hello do you feel better now that you're thawed out yeah here you go take the fishy
please don't throw the lollipop out of the cave entrance okay delicious oh wait
then where's the lollipop I'm going to sprint here give me the goddamn lollipop I know it's in
this room somewhere give me the goddamn lollipop I know it's in here is it is it another fish one
I mean about this damn game you want to swap that character and it puts you down on the ledge
mithril lego can be destroyed with I don't see mithril in here am I going crazy you're mithril
it's prompting me to destroy mithril ha there it is it's the lollipop wait
so then why was I getting stuck in other game please is there something mithril in here
it's prompting me to explode something why I don't see the mithril you are you
you don't look at
it's still prompting me to destroy mithril I'm not sure why
an ace lolly literally I think is it in here what is it prompting me into the sky
I don't know I just did it just to feel warfare oh I don't know no that's a gold coin I need to put
my glycs on she's really prompting me hard right now to do mithril explosives I don't know maybe
there's something up but by the guy but I don't I mean I think there's everything in here we got a
treasure and we've got an item she keeps prompting me why why are the hints prompting me to go nuts
what was that I saw that what are you aiming at
I'm just gonna let the auto aim tell me what's up but it looks like
I don't know what she's prompting me with no I don't know why you're prompting me
colladriel please why are you prompting me I think I've done everything in this cavern
no I don't know why she's doing that I don't know if she's building
okay time to jump
is she just gonna prompt me the entire game
she's like hey you really need to blow up mithril just like you should know
okay okay she really is wait is there a mithril in this area
I've already popped the stuff on the shore
I think she just bugged out she bugged
glad you'll be like oh
let's jump up up see pop see
we're making some money in this round 118,000 that's like the most money I've ever made
I don't even have any multipliers on
wow tap tap tap tap tap tap
I'm really happy about it it's been a long time for me coming
Sam can dig why does that take me so long there is what if I go I'm missing an item in a treasure
I can't even remember where it is I'm just gonna try and get the majority of the effortless transition
of strony between lego ethotery the status of her bowels and genuinely insightful business
analytics is all the proof you need that being a successful adult and being a grown up are two
different things love our streamer x that is funny see when you list stuff out like that it makes
me realize how ridiculous this all is like literally I get to play like a little childhood
game I get to dirt about lords of rings I'm also fucking we don't idle meetings up in this
thank you so much Oregon that was hilarious sorry brother horses backfruits messed up
oh yeah yeah I'm kind of like wobbling wobble the wobble the what wobble the most backhanded
no never grow up sorry but my dad when he saw me he was actually really happy he was like I'm so
glad you didn't grow up um oh my thrill we did it we thank you collateral we did it what is it
what is it we did it collateral after all of that after all of that
and getting older is mandatory growing up wait growing up is actually my dad was like I'm so
glad you never changed or anything and I'm like why would it change because he always says like oh
you're so successful like I'm so glad that you earn money to like support yourself and you seem to
really love what you do and I'm like yeah I literally fucking have a carry on like oh yeah
you don't groom the girls but this is how you groom them xd in a script um type thing and he was
really happy to see that like I've not changed or anything and he's like you know no one would
think that you make that kind of money if you go outside and I'm like I'm like what and he's like
yeah could you dress like a home like a homeless person I'm like uh dad dad xd dad xd
um he loves saying that to me he's like oh could you dress in a hoodie and leggings and not an
else and I'm like yeah I mean have I ever shown any interest in like fashion or anything like no
literally like I was because we were walking past like um we're in a shopping district and we're
walking past and um the guy's like trying to sell folk a car or something but um he was like trying
he was suiting up like whatever you were dressed like I can't figure out where the flag oh there is
um obviously the guess would buy you're dressed if you're in the like money to be able to buy it
type thing and obviously we never got like a you know approached or anything for it um
and uh my dad loves going like oh oh shawnee they'd never know they'd never know and I'm like yep
let's keep it that way because he loves it I never like I don't buy like any design or
shite I'd never understood it I can't get behind it I'm too brain dead does this make
strongy the first tom fish girlfriend the truly rich and confident one they're well
I mean you and your garments for a few days well literally no wonder I didn't even spend any of
my money I didn't even need to buy washing up tablets at the rate that I go through my clothes
I'd be like I'd rather sit when they close and all of it needing to be washed and like
buck ass naked than actual washing it and like spending my money on it to do the tom food
dress homeless to avoid interaction is like exactly right we're just gonna go up here and
then this should be the last one and then I think we're done that's 10 yeah we did it okay
that's our first perfect one let's go save and exit well yeah oh yeah this is our first
perfect game
act broke just oh do we have a million no we don't we're just shy of a million
hydration check reflames I avoid interaction by walking only in alleyways you'll never get
rally far ooh what is the miniature
it's the mountain
huh huh what is that supposed to be
okay we got three I um so in the actual uh middle air that you can play in people will
ask you for quest items that you only obtain
why would you need more clothes honestly I think okay I hide weighted
you reduce your chances of getting pickpocketed oh I get fucking profiled all the time because
I use a backpack in the shops and they always go like open your bag and I'm like okay
and then when I talk they like change their tune that I think they don't expect the Scottish accent
I'm just like yeah yeah in in in Europe in Europe we use bags we use bags within the bag
here we pay for bags with your charges no we just use backpacks
no I don't know I don't say anything like that I just know they're doing they get told
to do that I'm doing their job okay can we do this one
I don't know I can't remember everything in this one
I'll try my best I'll try my best to do it first time but uh if the other two levels or anything
to go by I'm messing up okay Sam's doing that Legolas is doing this yep do this one key okay
oh you need a key it's trying so hard yeah well honestly to be honest I've accidentally almost
stolen from a shop twice now so actually to be fair yeah it's probably good that they check my
backpack and stuff I keep trying to accidentally steal medicine because it's free in Scotland
I know I say this story all the time but it's happened twice now that I've almost walked out of
the shop and they always get mortified and then I always have to be like tee he please don't arrest
me I'm actually just a foreign cunt please please I want my hands and knees don't arrest me I'm a
good girl I swear I mean just it's a foreign concept that you can't you know medicine's free and stuff
like your citizens are sick and you know they they pay taxes and stuff I don't know
gee crazy whale analysis that maybe maybe health care should be mildly for free if you want you
know people pay the taxes and stuff I don't know crazy concept don't listen to me what I know I'm
just a whore on the internet oh that does Mickey Mouse sometimes but not to be confused with the
adventure time the classic thieving scrawny stories on a clue I'd make a terrible thief
baby
medicine's free
right we're gonna do the wee background stuff first I think if we pull out two of these we do
get something by Berserker no don't do that no don't do that go like that then didn't be an oracle
I hate when you go there scrawny walks in grabs something off the shelf and walks out like no no no
so like if it's prescribed medicine I can't comprehend like it just doesn't compute in my
brain just yet that like if it's prescribed to you because you need it for medical like health
reason that it's not free because in Scotland everything is free you have asthma your inhaler
is free you have type 1 diabetes and type 2 for that matter the insulin is free because you need
that stuff to live and breathe so it's provided for free because you know um oh is that the term
oh my gosh that's the term of thing in my boba oh
oh
uh health care system good but as we've done yeah I've to admit going to pay going from public
like the nhs to private Aussie I've to admit at least in Aussie land every doctor I've ever
spoken to actually listens to what I'm saying whereas in Scotland I've got just eight more
and I was dealing with being perpetually tired and it took me like a month to get this appointment
with my doctor and I explained all my symptoms I said like I'm just exhausted I like I get like
10 hours of sleep every night and all of this stuff and eat I could sometimes sleep 12 hours
and it just never feels like I get enough and um you know the male it was a guy doctor
and and before you let me know why you're bringing up male because um you'll learn in a second relax
um basically um he his advice to me was eat more didn't run any blood tests didn't take my heart
great um blood pressure anything of that accord like literally nothing couldn't give less of a
shit um and then I come to Australia and I asked for a blood test and they're like of course of
course um got the blood test literally same day results were in two days they're like your border
line anemic please eat uh like red meat please take iron supplements like high-grade iron
supplements they said your vitamin D deficiency will also attribute to your tiredness and all this
um and yeah I've like literally been flopped off by every Scottish doctor I've ever had
uh come to Australia I pay a cheeky a hundred dollars and like I'm literally being treated
really so much kindness they listen to all my problems and say um oh no the the fucking
I need your spot
um what are you doing
okay there that's the the mark uh so he was kind of right eat more well no because I was so far
gone I needed supplements they literally said I was one marker away from needing a blood transfusion
because um I needed iron and the I can't get enough of it in my diet which is why I have to
take supplements for it I swear if he pops my calls I'm going to be raging ready for this
oh I'm too early
I was kind of joking okay there we go I was a wee bit early but um iron deficiency
yeah literally uh I spoke to my Aussie doctor and she was like I'm not even kidding
all the majority of women are like severely iron deficient just by default and I'm like
rip us rip us literally none of us feel well we all feel ill
popped your a lit oh I did it again just oops I did it again
get lashed in my face oh man need more minerals I require minerals
god let this battle be over I don't even know what I'm supposed to do oh to get like last
oh and like last just popped a slot
get lovely lovely jubilee none of us can climb up on my side build
I'm gonna build this right now oh yeah
well me needs more ink if ink had iron and it'd be over for you mother
it would be over you wouldn't get a day of fucking peace for me if your ink had iron
and I'm coming for you iron earned and iron earned oh shit I'm not Legolas gonna no I need to be
Legolas I just shit on my ass stop please oh my god you annoy me so much I hate in the game
you know you don't want to shoot at him
are you pissing my arse
and then he goes right back into the corner where he's like miles away and I'm one HP so I'm about
to get twatted by this fucking thing okay that actually worked out really well oh my god did you
see that dodge oh my god did you see that lego dodge sorry I've never I've never you will never
see smoother gameplay oh just notice that Frodo is sitting there injured oh no he's like right
next to me sorry Frodo I suck secret vampires running along oh real and true
oh
sorry that's really stuck on my head it's because I mean song was finished I'm just waiting on the
no
right skip to do the gippity day my oh my what a wonderful day
plant e of sunshine and refling's incoming my way
doing some quick google math you would need seven points to refling ink in every day skittin it
wait it has iron in it
I didn't know that uh refling's hold on a minute I already know my next fucking meta plot oh no
the honey tea kind of did that didn't it oh well he's okay I'll get to work here damn straight
this is
take this and this and this and this and this
the level of iron and nickel and human ink where
the farm milking table you want a milking table audio I will give you the fuck out of a milking
table seven rounds in one audio
seven rounds in one audio yes or no I will do that I will do that seven rounds in one audio
yes or no now I don't actually want you to go seven rounds but I'll write seven scenarios for it
and call it mommy needs iron strong he needs iron ASMR when right fucking now please can I write
you're crazy please let me do please
blood is rich in iron okay maybe a vampire audio at a later date though
the purpose of the farm is for mommy to get iron do it okay say no more I don't know if you've ever
seen the um if you've ever seen the memes on TikTok that's like um
if you're gonna um like if I'll give you dada if you jump in the water but they never even finished
the sentence like the person already jumps in the water literally me like I'm already there you
don't have to say no more to me I just need a simple yes and I'm off on one I'm even kidding
ooh I might be able to get true adventure if I don't mess this up too much
what is this what was that I saw that was key oh it's a skeleton key
vitamin D and iron supply wait is it got vitamin D in it as well the fuck
I better start developing an appetite right I said everyone on pineapple pizzas right now
do you understand me everyone order a pineapple pizza right now oh no with ham it has to have
ham and pineapple okay there's a golem wall here I can see it
yes moment why ham um um mommy I will defend this to the death so the reason why ham and pineapple
pizza work so well is because you've got the sweetness of the pineapple the salty kind of tartness
oh uh golem uh huh oh oh golem don't sit ah what hold on a minute what's going on here I know the
wall isn't come up uh excuse me golem okay right and then angle it and uh huh uh huh uh no no no
golem what are you doing I know the wall isn't complete but I don't want to uh uh uh uh I don't
want to do frame ah I don't want to do frame perfect why would they do this
no no no that was just how is it been I'm literally edgy ah come on wait is it wait
wait wait I've just spotted this is this the rest of the wall in here what this is impossible it's
literally not letting me do it wait what strong character no that Sam do you don't have a rope on you
why gives me the Sam that doesn't have a rope give me the Sam with a rope
sweet and savory it's awful it's imami wait so that's so really wait is there really no more to
this wall am I actually right relax Balrog sorry I'm tackling this wall wait how am I supposed to do
this without
you ever get in those situations where you make things harder for yourself for no reason yeah
yeah uh sometimes something I mean I mean I guess like I don't mean it on purpose
kind of for people in here yeah because the ham's like got savory as well oh gandalf around
I don't know why because we can just turn to gandalf maybe something in play test and make them do that
I don't like when savory things are sweet no it's a mix it's umami it's all together all together
all together what up oh Sam are you okay was he I think he's stuck to the path I'm
coming over strong are you gonna make me want no you're already puking off when I'm late for
like three seconds I was like literally you should just see the message on the my patreon
post is so short as well because I was literally that gif like typing in all the tags like okay
side job okay big job right what next what happened in the script like literally and then
like uploaded it and then I came through and an absolute panic like oh god okay need to set up stream
like the descriptive is so short it's so short so that uh he's just gone
okay do that
I'm beating stuff up with the key like replayings I have your chat
respectable behavior why are you saying that out loud with such confidence
your mommy is the flavor of the strong if you ever do a convention you should call it the iron
supplement to me donate oh my god no honestly don't think I want mommy I'm away ahead of you
I have pineapple pizza at home mother I'm way ahead of you I have pineapple pizza at home
literally it it don't know why everyone freaking mocks it it's so good
get under stuff why is this so hard to put on a wall what the heck I don't know why that was
all obtuse like that but we did it anyway thank you brulee legend for agreeing with my perfect
taste okay don't worry if you don't like pineapple and pizza I'm making a hitness this audio about it
already picked up that I am okay and that's a safe situation there is a myth real thing yeah
I'm just like sorry I'm actually just so good I know it's weird seeing someone just so MLG at
game before but oh no oh I remember this this is awful you're I don't know if this is a gunny's
reference I can't remember if it is remote so it's gonna rotate and we need to like cause it on red or
something wait okay so on red we need to that's pink I thought it was a gunny's reference
or no I don't know if it is or not but it's like all highlighted as well if you're like blind like me
no you cannot I will never yield to pineapple pizza well that's the whole point of the head no
wait wait I'm not done there's more wait hold on a minute it's supposed to be three and done
that's how these games work
no I missed ow it stopped me that's so good wait so I need it one more time
bruh give it to me
oh wow this is going too fast for me
my framerate I don't have that much good framerate okay we're getting pennies bro
in for a penny in for a pound can you hypnotize you it's not like in peace as good as yum yum
we're gambling no no no no no we're not gambling okay there's one up there dad just should it
no I don't know
oh right I was literally just hit it again right okay what we go we're missing one item and one
treasure hmm I have no idea where they are uh I'm trying to think ahead
not to the beard
unless unless a little bit of the beard you know
off you go
you won
okay we know what do you do
we need to go down to Sam right
right someone's gonna be
and then we get a little secret I think we might be able to get through adventurer
if I don't end up jumping off the map or anything I'm wasting my xp
wasting my money hydration check little replan
wow
I don't know what you're doing
it's been fun I'll continue to watch the vlog see you next time bye weakland thank you for hanging
as always um this is a very long stream today unless something happens to my guts I don't know
um but I do plan on finishing this game up if I can I seem to think I can I'm quite confident
um oh no please don't glitch out
imagine if you didn't glitch out right now oh wait hold on a minute
controversial take I I think I'm gonna get the last uh item
uh the last like things here if I just ignore the Gandalf and Balrog fight I'm sorry but it's
kind of true though no you're such a cheat the game would like give me a second pair since
I need to go back to Gandalf you're so stinky right fine we'll do the Balrog fight even though I
don't want to because it glitches out all the time right it does he's getting closer so it's not
glitching out nothing uh pretty cheap on Gandalf's part to tell the party to run so we can get all
the XP but yes as always um shitting on stream no uh please do not feel forced to um lurk or hang
out I am going to be online for a very long time today so if you have responsibilities you need two
or things you gotta get done don't worry I ain't un-solid I'm beating him I'm beating him as soon as
YouTube implement like the times three feature then you guys will be able to keep up with my
streaming but for now don't worry about it I ain't un-solid although I'm probably going to sound
like a chipmunk on times three I already sound a bit sneakier on times two um but I understand that I
do not stream like that regular schmagular um I'm out I stream too much if you will
far too much
oh wow okay that's one or is that two actually hold on a minute hold on a minute I think it was two
imagine not watching streaming 0.5 I I probably sound drunk on 0.5 I wouldn't I wouldn't even tolerate
that there's a plugin that lets you do times 10 cook how are you even supposed to understand the
thing I'm saying I love the idea that you can tell when I'm like saying something outrageous
because my voice just goes like even though you can't understand the words the brain it's too good
beat them up beat them up beat them up beat them up hey smack them smack them
ha ha
I'm on you I'm on your shoulder beating a fowl rock oh oh oh oh I'm completing these 100
completion
yo if you play animal crossing you'll understand
so if like a lot of stays on that I should be able to grab it yeah I thought that I thought that
thing we got um an artist's hat oh Gandalf's hat oh his hair doesn't like the asset
okay so where's the last one
it must be in this room popium surely the last treasure is here
is it not here wait is there there must be like mithril or something right surely copium
wait what's this I don't know is it in here why is it is it not here
I'm just digging into a wall right now look at the war well sure give me true adventure at least
I just don't have to secret thing that has the last treasure in it no what I messed up
where is it
there's a is that a Frodo cave down there it's not the one on the wall by the way I have done the
one on the wall reading 10 times subtitles as well I know I just cannot keep up with that
is there a Frodo cave down here that I spotted is this for Frodo
oh oh don't do that to me game don't do that to me I'm such a freaking fake gamer
imposer don't do that to me again you understand I thought mithril see you you're first
get right right we're done we're out of here we're out of here
oh I can't keep up with this sorry I like the music it's actually pretty cute okay that's
the second fully completed level we're doing it we're doing it
how is a bit rusty on the other two that we started with okay but that's because the games
requiring me to have like these um like a bow and arrow and stuff oh we did it and we got adventure
as well turn down f in the chat for my boy yandere oh boy oh yeah it's mr crabs
what did we meet oh the bow rog oh with this we went oh my god a bow rog this was shibiko did feel
oh not bad not bad oh hit him with a millionaire category uh I think I'd like to start uh purchasing
multiple properties and renting them an astronomical price uh I think I'd like to affect the market
for the average person and say diddoms because you didn't pull themselves up by the bit straps
uh I think I'd like to buy this plot of land and turn it into a multiple duplexes
where there don't have any garden space uh
sorry oh my god sorry I need to stop because I'm sure some people are really listening and
they'll be like what the fuck I'm not I'm not listening to this anymore I'm like bro relax
but at the same time it's kind of funny oh I think I'll use my credit card
um we don't have the recipe for mithril boxing gloves so we can't I'm a bit nervous I'm actually
gonna see if we can at least make the bow and arrow and breathe um because we're starting to get
to the point where we're gonna come across quite a few missions that um we can't do like the 100
percent on because we lack the required items so I'm gonna see if we unlocked a bow and arrow or not
ooh we need the cluster bow
then we actually need it for middle earth missions you have to like kill multiple targets beanie
legs snowflake it's called humor reel landlord other rings honestly I say that as if I don't
absolutely love incremental games sorry I love getting rich in video games I don't know I just
I just oh oh my god oh and like especially when it's like a slow burn progress one
and then like you're all rich by the end of it oh you just need galvanized steel and eco friendly
wood to extend your apartment complex by six square meters oh yeah
um it's the integral part of the strutting experience reminds me I need to extort the
rentals more this month literally what's that your job reduced your hours because you stood up
for yourself and you have three children to home sorry not my problem yeah no wonder people feel
so disconnected yeah they are more of these music books a headdress icebow well let's just make the
stuff why not let's make some stuff we don't really make any material stuff yet so I'll just spend
I'll spend my myth through it look I feel like splurgeon this is the kind of splurgeon I do it's
in video games only okay you should see me in the binding of Isaac shops I'd be blowing the
out of my donation machine okay actually can I tell you the really bad tactic I do in binding
of Isaac I play as the keeper because he drops like tons of coins when you kill enemies and then
I shove them in the donation machine and then I just kill myself on purpose to keep adding more once
it clogs um so I have tons of money in my donation machine for other runs I'm not here for the
win streak okay oh it's aces um figurine it's quick story so cute kawaii ne
um yeah sure we'll just make the little bits and bobs um bits and bobs will do our jobs
okay yeah he doesn't do any other kind of splurging only if you just blanking yeah
I still need to buy that headset
I'll do that audio I don't care how cursed it is I think it's funny
everyone asking for a part two on the pregnancy no I'm gonna give you a whole new series
just straight up vor but actually this time yeah yeah actually boring we're breaking free we're
boring trying yeah there's not a hole but I can you put a microphone in if you're trying
I'm so sorry to those of you who listen and at work
you're just like fucking absolutely flabbergasted that this is the running commentary at work
in your ear right now you're like okay baby and you're like you're like when I get home today
I'm unsubscribing I'm unsubscribing from the youtube channel after that remark
I splurge on contraption no this woman I feel like to make an amazing you might enter the gunjian
it's a very similar type of game it keeps me entertained in the morning yeah makes my work
doable I don't know I like hearing that you guys like have a good time so I'm just me even around
in the background like do you listen with your work headphones or do you have it like playing on
your phone with an earphone and your ear type thing because like I've never worked an office job I
work tons of different job types but an actual office job where like they can see your search
history and stuff I don't you don't have to be like a sneaky wee bam because they'll pull you up
and they'll be like uh anon who is strongy and why is she putting you in her why is she
pregnant with you ASMR like why like don't they see everything so you have to like do it on your phone
on your phone yeah headphones earbuds do not no don't try enter the gunjian okay
work laptop and work headphones oh yeah because it increases my productivity real and true you
can literally argue for that oh pardon me sorry delivering mail makes it easy oh my god you're
like trucking on the roads wait what if you're laughing at something I say and then like everyone
driving by you's just like wow that anon's having a really good day meanwhile your headset and then
I'm gonna shove you up my ass in the audio roleplay and then after I grim you I did like
like literally that's the everyone's POV is like oh it's just a really happy delivery man he's just
having a really good time and then in the ears like anyway so this is what happened behind the scenes
and all these different things going on most streams yeah yeah okay oh we have a rope for
everyone now okay okay I'm listening while getting destroyed in Isaac oh my god can I tell you when
I first started playing Binding of Isaac I used to struggle with spiders so much like I literally had
to reach but the game um I was so bad at it what a cute girl I wonder where she's listening to you
companies make more money because of strong audio they approach strong for business deal
oof nee that's what I was so surprised when we actually got like legitimate investment offers
I'm like you didn't realize the split is 80-20 and the challenge favor right like what like we never
responded to any of them I was like I'm no wasting my fucking time with that pitch but like I think
what they saw was 80-20 and they're like 80% of the income goes to the company I want to slice
that pie and it's like no you're fucking wrong like literally and wait so I do all the work and set
it all up but you get like a wee cheeky investment thing like no go away go away don't if you want
to invest in the girls go clip them go go ship them in appropriate places like don't come to me
being all my girls this all my girls that fuck you bitch I have no idea where these blocks blocks and
but boxing big boxing gloves are but I need them soon to him um because there's gonna be like a few
missions we can't complete without the boxing mithril boxing one I'm just gonna have to come
across them naturally I'm invested the talents only get 20% brah someone legitimately thought that
recently and I'm like there is no way in hell you can motivate people to work no this is literally
the very mission I don't know if we need mithril boxing gloves for it this is the very mission I
had in mind where we needed the crossbow right spank the crap out of these okay okay we might be able
to do this one we might be able to do this one okay not a big fan of each of our agencies
important part in seeing viewers pretty good so far uh yes it's kind of a self-owned type singing
my barber and because of that reason um you know there's no greed and the whole point is like
you know no greed basically um it's very hard to be uh you know it doesn't mean everything's
perfect behind the scenes it's the first time dealers have ever done any of this part of this
nature um and it can't all go perfectly smooth and all that jazz but um you know I'd like to think
the girls feel like they get paid fair for their work and um obviously after the most recent meeting
um you know a lot of things were realized on my end in particular anyway that was like oh I'm
literally just being an arsehole and thinking a by accident I'm pretty sure no one thinks
that he's doing anything maliciously I was kind of just like oh this is I know this so you should do
this and you know um but yeah as I said hopefully the girls agree that we do what we can but um
I mean not everyone might agree to that but whatever it's obviously a dealer's passion
I'm glad yeah I really did not um I the the money grab is pretty it's pretty gross especially when
um people join an agency to get um more popular to get more um to get uh to become a self-sustaining
content creator and all that and like to dash those dreams or that faith that um someone would place
in an agency due to greed as well you know to me is morally rather um rather rough rather rough
I think that's fair to say and um you know it's why I'm quite keen on the concept of
content creator owned retailer agencies because of the fact they know what making content is like
they know you can't even just wham bam thank you ma'am is this what comes first no the other one
it was a one in three so this one's first then it's this one then it's this one
oh they're gonna kiss oh they kissed and give me that thank you for kissing
I don't think the boats do anything other than give money I'm guessing yeah there's not really much
going to boat better than super oh really you can't say such things out loud with such a
refilling inside voice if I get one more it's actually stopped but if I get one more save the
blue one brother you're done you're they're all getting golden snakes honestly I'm sure I probably
spurred it on by accident when I mentioned what that I got messages like that but I have to admit
that was some I was like I was very surprised I'm like why am I the first thought in the situation
babe I was rather entertained right is there any branches or anything I don't think so
no thank you I don't think this is a cheeky one winner is too hidden I think that catapult system
is the next kind of like cheeky wiki one right when you whack all the stat use there should be
three on this side and three on Frodo's side which is why we have that bow and arrow now
because we can't actually access it if we don't have that bow and arrow all right we are going to
destroy the aragon aragon paragon statue yay and then I think we get something for that
that's through you oh no it's three of four right is there one up ahead
what do you hope there's one up ahead I'm not prepared if around
no but it's it's been fun really big learning curve as well um
you know if gen two do get confirmed um there'll be a lot more things in place to
especially the interview stage uh as much as I enjoyed the laxity laxity well that's not right
as much as I enjoyed the very like informal interview with them I think I'm going to have
to be pretty direct and be like uh you do actually have to do stuff please don't think the agency
does absolutely everything for you um because I kind of ran into that issue a little bit
um
but um no it's been a it has been an absolutely lovely learning experience um
I've thoroughly enjoyed it so far I mean shit we're only entering the third month so
there's still a lot to learn a lot to give um a lot to do um and it's just uh
it's been enjoyable so far it's been very knowledge like knowledge gaining um I have thoroughly
enjoyed kind of learning new things for the first time um there is an enemy under
wait I can only access photo shire no that can't be right
get your torture you bam yeah look at me arsenal on the spot he always gets the hitting like no
matter what you do and he'll always get that hit okay wait it's just money under here there's no
item oh right I was gonna say I didn't I didn't think that was quite right
wait so does that mean the dealer staff get more than the livers
you're not comforting well because it's all contract based there's not like a salary for
anyone a dealer um it's all variable contracts like it's literally nothing's written in this
one's gonna have to do anything I'm glad we get to experience it with you together
it literally is just so nice right when you whack the statue there we go I am going to purposely
swap to photo now because I believe I've done what I can in this area um now we are in shadow
ray form unfortunately so it is going to be a bit this takes forever um but we'll get to it and I'm
gonna pray I'm not gonna forget anything major um the likelihood of me forgetting something major
pretty high um and iron and blood what does that mean is that from a game I don't know
right this is where we need the bow and arrow for this section coming up
life is one big learning experience it is and there's been nothing but like
um you know I'm trying not to be so hard on myself for areas that I did feel like I've failed a bit
and as I said I've kind of like go in terms of like trying my best I want to word it maliciously
because it's not malicious I'm just trying to be like look this is what happened I wanted them to
see me as a gen mate but you know after discussion and stuff it's very clear they don't so I'm not
gonna force it like I'm not gonna do that you know right that's why we needed that wait whoa
I dropped the wait I dropped the ring am I going mental did that not just say press B to pick up the
ring I don't know what just dropped there but something certainly did um right there should be six
that use um veiler is a fellowship of the ring
right there we go boom there was one behind here but I don't think we have to do it
I've had really friendly bosses before but it's kind of hard to ignore the authority yeah like I
really didn't want that but after like all the feedback discussion and everything it's better
to just accept but yeah it can't happen and there's no point crying over spilt milk
they might turn around
I've been surprised before you know I don't know I don't want to I mean I know the pricing sense I
just mean it is like a fact sense and like it caused a lot of stress obviously like all the stress
has been building off and I've kind of been telling you is how it's been going in that
and you've all been like listening to me send me kind messages on marshmallow but
it just feels like the stress is gone because I've let go like of something so badly that
was trying to make happen and it's like I don't need to do that to myself
it always takes a while but it's a bit of undertone here um
is this a secret area no right we need to destroy an eyeball or something up ahead
and then it'll I think it's a catable I think I need to do the cat fault again or something
I can't remember
is that the wrong one is this supposed to do the other eye
I'm supposed to do something with a bloody cat halt but I can't remember these
sorry the arrows are stuck on the helm
okay oh dear um oh dear oh dear oh dear that was not intended to happen but it happened
uh was it quite my intention there right so what we rebuild this and work it again
oh
okay I knew we had to go back to the catapult but I almost didn't see that wait did I do him
I must stop he didn't count right okay
I'll know when I'm at the end of Frodo's as well because his is up at the stairwell
and
right six out of ten but it's not the band
pd got any alerted or anything's lore you want to draw um
uh um uh uh uh um sometimes I don't have anything on the on my main grid now that one
that I can think of
no no I used to sleep to the behind the scenes stuff I'm surprised my brain can't just be like
like rapping all of all um the movies took over a year to record and like whale over a year every
single day doing the same thing um Sean Aston and big ally would used to count every day they had
to get the feet put on them but the feet weren't in the shot it happened quite a lot where the
prosthetics were put on their feet um but then um uh the feet weren't even in any of the shots
um which is quite a wee shame because it takes them very long time to
get all that stuff put on and Gimli the reason his eyes are messed up in the shots like you
can hardly see him he was allergic to the latex but nothing else was working and his prosthetics
would fall off almost immediately um which is such a shame oh my god please tell me we have
my throw rope oh thank goodness how'd I get up there don't need to be below it
what am I doing jumping on it oh no I need an axe see this is that I never crafted an axe did I
I never crafted an axe
have an axe of any accord
oh have a trial a fishing rod a cluster bow I don't have an axe to walk through the ground yet
this is what annoys me about this boom
is you can't do the main missions without the secret eye like the mithril stuff as well
oh dear oh dear oh dear I can go back to the levels but I was hoping to kind of
blast through all of them but we need the recipe for the axe but unfortunately I don't have it
so Gimli like he said Frodo he'd have his axe honestly so that's us we've done this section at
least and but yeah as we come back we can kind of blast through the areas that
I'll run if you do great okay we're doing this one
I can I can do this one okay but we will go back for that let me come back out where you're doing
I still think you're talking about the cat I'm getting confused as well I'm like wait a minute
why am I referring to the him as Gimli I've an achievement called pointy-eared elvish
break because I destroyed kill funny oh no 42 I killed 42 okay 42 that's still only counts as one
um oh yeah and Gimli's actor everyone so Gimli in real life is like humongous what he's
absolutely massive he's built like a tank um and when they were doing the mock of the face
he'd be like right you come here first right you come here you come here you do this you do that
and then boom bobs your uncle and he would like actually whack up the prop people because he I
don't know he just that's how he did it um he would like actually whack them up and stuff is
Gimli's beard real no let's get this yeah beat him up with a frying pan beat him up beat him up
right there is an uh area down here here we go oh berserker you're just a person I need
please put your bombs back on for one and then two little secret area I always loved the little
secret areas and like the hidey holes and stuff I find them so cute if I'm not mistaken which I
always almost am I'm building something I don't recognize this area very well
right let's do gimmels
is it just money down here okay that's me unless there's something going on oh is that berserker
on the other side okay we'll just follow the path up I can't recall if there's any fine then keep
your secret I can't recall if there's any major secrets I see a Sam see a Sam we'll make us a
little fire keep talking mommy I'm trying not to fall asleep on the train wake up it's the first of
the month careful not to fall asleep on the train isn't that thing is that just money over there
I'm not really that fuss for money money because I've already got adventure um a beard like that
is a dream please your beard at night ASMR and compliments it or something where am I going oh
okay we got it we're at nine out of ten though hmm actually I'm just gonna go up berserker and get
the heck out here is there anything special maybe in the last mission
I'm gonna go gimmels gonna go legola no well sure I'll throw you as well why not
no I won't throw you apparently I don't know why I'm guessing because I'm not uh
yeah okay berserker can pick up but can't fall down
okay no she's just a fake friend she does it to get attention that's so okay I'm so glad
you guys can laugh at this story because I can't ever read it bearded girlfriend anything you want
for gen four I'll I'll put all the listed things down I actually told you that joke
I mean she thought that was funny but right there is
isn't all things to hit around the map I just want to just hit me
excuse me I'm trying to do this low hey put me down put me down put me down get the fuck
am I soft locked okay no
okay oh my god I literally thought I was soft locked there because the game registers both
as weians right I'm going to like last really quickly oh wait no that's what I wanted
what's that one of six okay one of six and then one of six oh I see him I see him I see him one
two three I see I see him do you mind do you mind I'm trying to shoot animals here
or little silhouette things right what's that is that everything no we're missing an item
is that must have been the way the um okay so that's everything we can do until we can come back
with an axe a mithril axe okay so I'm happy with that we did our best but we need to come back
with an axe what happened to gen three nothing um the the insider joke is if someone asks for
something that I absolutely do not want or do not like I say yeah gen four yeah yeah gen four
um that that's the inside joke okay so only you know about it and be like oh and then you have
to be like oh I can't wait for gen four yeah yeah I bet you can't wait gen four is like the cake
from Portland the cake is alive sonic we see for gen four she's got like a sonic just straight up sonic
voice actor check on a chick a true adventure once in a lifetime exactly yes we don't warg attack
maybe can all be done without any item praying I'm praying copium absolute copium I know for a
fact a mount doom can't be done without like these boxing gloves things so we might have to actually
do some all right no no no stop stop stop stop stop I'm trying to get work done okay
first we do this and then we blow them up
what did that reveal oh it's a crown okay sure put a crown on berserker why not a giant ancient crown
um I think there's a few gimly smashes on the floor if I'm not mistaken
and then for some reason it makes like a little horsey stand I don't know what it
but if you destroy them you get one of two the last one here okay
I don't think I can support Vila anymore giraffe beach of her's in my thing no it's a zebra
someone asked for a zebra the other day and I was like yeah yeah yeah
giraffes where I draw the line oh we've got a little sand thing here I like when rooms are
really cohesive like this where there's like tons of stuff to do it just in one go
it's literally so I love it it's so fucking easy I love when like all the stuff is just sitting
ready I love it I love it I love it right is there anything else in this room that looks
it's mighty suspicious now I know the white kind of glowing effect on everything is very distracting
it is um maybe we'll do this hold on hold on we're just gonna spank everything can I hit these
I can't is it just money okay I want to say that's everything in this area yeah it's just like
picking up spears and stuff okay uh I see a bit of gold spank the gold can break the gold right
that's fine we'll just make them in and then we'll do Gandalf and then we'll do magic
and then we're gonna let we're gonna not get hit by swapping to the other teammate
I'm a lamprey what's a lamprey now you're giving me now you're just making up words for gen four
you're gonna ask for me for a boobly woobly next or something for gen four I don't know what that is
I don't know what it means did I get your adventure this round oh I did okay I don't need to do that
right wall of him and then let him get stuck in the trap
there you go take sweet time and then he'll break out I'll swap and then boom you don't get hit
oh Gandalf just perished because of my little cheeky maneuver there like it was it I was an
accident okay I like my vtuber absolutely lamprey is a jawless fish
a chin you want a chinless fish for gen four what the fuck are you even suggesting
what are you even you want a chinless vtuber
what are what are you saying to me basically a giant mouth with teeth
okay now this is gonna be a lot so I need to be gimley then I need to come off the horse
then I need to be legless yeah this area is like who can massive right gimley you need to like
actually come over maybe nope off the horse fall off the horse then you get back on it okay I'm trying
to do something and we do just have to leave the enemies in the background sadly because there's
nothing we can do if we end up perishing them we'll push forward the like a lot more basically
which we don't want because we might be gen four is going to be the biggest gen in any agency ever
literally oh my god imagine if I just like right one last one last run and it's like a hundred girls
are released at once and I'm like ah fuck it you'll make a little vtuber history on the way out
be like ah that's me done right here's a hundred girls enjoy
talk about saturate I'll you want to talk about a saturated vtuber market I'll saturate it myself
fuck you here's a hundred girls released saturate it
me
ready go for all the flow okay there's no flowers let's go over here just
see the hour going
and then we'll do the berserker thing I guess we'll just go left to right
me
oh that's right I've got that carrot I'm on that
I smell you sheebie I know exactly where you've put this
oh yeah I smell it oh yeah
I've got an apple can you say apple
automatically converts every chapter into vtuber come one come order all all fucking vtweeters
are being defeated in one fell swooped by and I've already done it three times as if it and
it's right at the edge of the cliff yeah okay you're done we got an item we got decorative
ursushu this okay there's an item in here I can see a ledge down here so I guess we're
gonna go Frodo any fredos in the chat me me no not shire me wait
me me I'm a fredo lover do you remember when fredos used to be five fucking pens I remember
get that I am gimley take that mobile phone yank my problem now uh warg tooth now we have all
three items we need five more and we actually need the schematic let's hope it's all in this area if not
pepperage farm remember some fredos were fighting actually
oh well good thing I had berserker out that's right I already get because this is a secret cave
I can't even get in is it just money no no I was gonna say they don't just put money behind that
kind of stuff that's not how they normally do the games right legolas time I like how gimley's
walking around with the little sword that he picked up I need to grab it though come back
to the wizard stuff because I hate it the most I'm just so bad at manipulating the wizard stuff
it's like rough as anything
what what how much does he get what's that moment he's gonna make a little platform
fredo inflation I'm gonna be sick gen four funds remember to have actual galadriel just show
just straight up just have galadriel doing her thing I'll get the real actor for it thank you
for the gen four fun lord of storms I appreciate it right release about to get the schematic
please be an axe so I can go back to the almond hinge oh it doesn't even tell you what it is okay
and right
right we're gonna dig some stuff actually there's something I can dig up over here
and it seems on its own and oh no I know what I have to do I remember I have to do a horse race
I can't where's the other side of it there's like a horse racing course thing I have to do
I don't know I don't see it I'll do the Gandalf thing first excuse me excuse me I'm just trying
just trying to get my collectibles tariel gen four real oh my god stop I'll get a
fucking I'll get an elfin right now that's good I'm not being can I just stand on this and jump
it I mean that was pretty close okay okay I won't do that I'll behave I'll behave I'll dig it
off and I'll do some of it okay just a little bit I can't remember if there's an area past this point
oh dear but I can't oh the red one isn't finished
okay magic next
I need to do it in the right order to unlock something I don't think so my brain
is telling me no it's fine so if I'm eating my words by the end of this then oops but yeah
and then I need to do something with a steer throw
oh okay I found it I need to I need to tally work it as I run past okay let's grab the horse
let's get my sword out one oh hold on hold on give me a chance just keep
bro hit the that literally hit the dang thing okay where am I going oh okay yeah yeah jump the fence
I promise I'll jump the fence where is it oh I see it I see it I see it I can hardly see it though
okay there we go boom is that everything whoa we did it another perfect one let's go
let's go another perfect round
I like ones like that that wrap it up
so we got the three quest items so when we go around Middle Earth and they ask for it we can
be like oh we already have that he'll never guess what we already have rolling in money
1.4 million a giant ancient crown a warg tooth and decorative horseshoes
and we unlock the design
oh
is that is that what I think is is that the one I need
we're going to go back to Bree and make that because the mithril gloves or the mithril boxing
gloves give strength so we don't have to deal with any of the issues wait I it might work it
may not it might be the boxing gloves which we'll have to find out later today I don't know where
they're located but we are going to go craft those gloves because they seem pretty important
if I can get away with it
if I can get away with it give me give me give me and respect the thing of course
mithril gloves are only four as well
um did you remember to eat not yet replaying uh
uh maybe I should eat because I only ate once yesterday I when I ate my little chicken pie
on stream that's all I ate yesterday because I was really stressed but then I had an eight hour
sleep so we'll guess what am I body needed need nutrition women got feet this dumpy or am I supposed
to show you okay let me make this and then how about we do a really quick break and then I'll go
for a peep and uh we'll get me chicken pie okay look we made the boxing gloves
I'll put you in story mode as well okay so you guys can like watch the mission that we've already
done a billion times over okay okay that sounds like a different okay let me and turn you right
we're gonna call for a quick pp break okay um helm steve I get attacked right away the path of the
dead I don't get attacked right away so we actually can put you in that okay replay give me
one give me well it takes two minutes 30 to heat up well I'll make another cup of tea
I just might be friends I just might make another cup of tea okay everyone go stretch I'll go get
food I'll go get tea and then we'll play some more deal deal um just in case any of my gen mates
are up shebe is normally up at this time two hours emmy is up I don't know what they're actually
doing is they're taking the week off and mercy starts in seven hours there you go okay don't vomit
as I said give me like three minutes okay give me like three minutes well the kit maybe maybe
four minutes okay okay okay okay okay fine you're fine you're fine three two one
you
six thousand
less than half of what I'd hoped for
six thousand will not be enough to break the lines of the mortal
so
I take my leave
my lord elrond you're outnumbered you need more men
there are no those who dwell in the mountain
the answer to no one they will answer to the king of gondor
so
underway in a flame of the west forged from the shards of narsir
the man who can wield the power of his sword can summon to him an army more deadly than
any of the books this army put aside the ranger to come home you are born to be
what kind of harmony would linger in such a place one that is cursed
long ago the men of the mountain swore an oath to the last king gondor to come to his aid
to fight but when the time came when gondor's need was dire they fled banishing the darkness of
the mountain and so is the end of a curse never to rest until we have fulfilled their pledge
the way is shown
this was made by those who were here
uh
.